hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm investigating article 2 of the
Constitution which establishes the
executive branch of government
it's Article 2 that establishes the
office of the President of the United
States tells us who's eligible for that
role how they get elected and what
powers they have now today it seems very
natural to us that the executive branch
of the US government should be led by a
president but at the time of the
founding it wasn't at all certain that
that would be the case after all the
founders had just rebelled against a
monarchy where power was placed in the
hands of one individual
they'd been so nervous about executive
power that the first governmental system
of the United States the Articles of
Confederation didn't have an executive
branch at all so to learn more about
article 2 I sought out the help of some
experts professors Tsai Prakash is an
expert in the separation of powers
particularly executive powers and
teaches constitutional law foreign
relations law and presidential powers at
the University of Virginia School of Law
for more on the debate about what an
executive branch should look like I
talked to Professor Michael Gerhart he's
a leading constitutional scholar whose
specialties include civil rights civil
liberties and separation of powers so
professor Prakash why did the framers
choose to invest power in a president
were there any other options for an
executive branch they thought about
creating an Executive Council which
would have been composed of three or
more executives that would have jointly
exercised whatever executive power they
vested in the executive and so you might
have had like a triumvirate like they
had in Rome or an Executive Council like
they had in some states and they also
thought about doing something slightly
different which is to have a single
president but then require the president
to go to a separate Executive Council
before he made several important
decisions but in the end they decided we
like to concentrate executive authority
in the hands of
one person thinking that that would be
better for law execution better for
assigning responsibility it would bring
energy to the executive branch and you
know we the executive branch wouldn't be
Riven with dissent and dissension I
asked professor Gerhardt how long it
took the framers to decide on the form
the executive branch would take it was
something on which the framers came to
an agreement pretty quickly they came in
to Philadelphia and almost at the very
outset there was a proposal that came
forward from Virginia part of the
Virginia Plan and the Virginia plan
proposed a single executive who would
serve for seven years and not be
eligible for re-election the delegates
would eventually agree on certain
features which are now encapsulated or
can be found in article two I think one
of the tensions we see in the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights is
trying to create a structure for
government that's strong enough to do
what it needs to do but also one that
doesn't have too much power so that it
doesn't become a tyranny as you know the
the framers had seen in Europe so were
they nervous about having an executive
branch in the first place that's a great
question Kim you know we had a
confederation before the Constitution
was called the Articles of Confederation
and in that system we had Congress
acting as a plural executive and
Congress and the it's observers of
Congress thought that Congress wasn't
really well suited to to playing the
role of executive to supervising Foreign
Affairs and to supervising executive
officers both military and civilian and
so by the eve of the Philadelphia
Convention where they wrote the
Constitution there were quite a few
people saying we need to have a separate
executive we need to invigorate it with
Authority because if we do that we will
then have a successful new government
under the new constitution Alexander
Hamilton for example wanted an executive
who basically served for life he didn't
get it you can imagine that for many
delegates a an executive who could serve
for life would sound
awful lot like a king and that's exactly
what they had just rebelled against
other people said if you create a
unitary executive if you create the
single executive chief executive you're
gonna have a monarchy you're gonna have
someone who is intent upon seizing
powers of various sorts who's going to
you know want to install maybe a
hereditary monarchy somehow and that was
the tension between those who wanted to
have a stronger executive a stronger
single executive thinking that that
would be the best thing for the
government and those who thought that
you know that a single executive would
descend into a monarchy so I imagine it
was pretty tricky for the framers to
think how they could have an executive
branch that was powerful enough to get
things done but not so powerful that it
took on that tyrannical cast that they
were really eager to avoid so what
powers did the president eventually end
up having you know the presidents made
commander-in-chief of the army in the
Navy he has the power to pardon the
president has the authority to nominate
people to certain high-ranking office is
subject to the advice and consent of the
Senate
among those offices are included Supreme
Court justices the president has the
authority to be able to negotiate
treaties so he's got a host of
authorities and then there's the central
question that's disputed Kim which is
does the first sentence of article 2
which says the executive power shall be
vested in the president United States
does that also give the president any
authority beyond what's listed in
articles article 2 sections 2 & 3 so for
instance does the vesting clause of
article 2 give the president authority
over law execution right is he able to
direct the execution of federal laws by
subordinate executive officers does the
president have the power to remove
executive officers by virtue of the
vesting clause and then significantly
does he have foreign affairs authorities
by virtue of the best in clause to speak
to other nations to direct US
ambassadors etc and that's it that's
that's a dispute that's been ongoing for
200 years whether the vesting clause
really grants additional authorities to
the president so all those different
powers we now more or less take for
granted that are common to u.s.
presidents are all set forth for the
most part expressing in the Constitution
there are few implicit powers the
president will take on over time as I
understand it the president's powers
have grown fairly significantly over
time do you think the framers would be
surprised by how much power the
president has today yes it's it's grown
I think to be perhaps more powerful than
many of the framers initially thought it
might be there were some authorities for
example the power to remove people in
the executive branch that are not
spelled explicitly in the Constitution
over time the presidency would acquire
that power and ultimately the Supreme
Court of the United States would ratify
that or affirm that authority that's one
big area removal power over executive
branch officials that gets clarified and
sharpened over time over time the
president has cited president and his
assistants have cited the vesting clause
is a source of a great amount of
authority and some of those claims you
might think are consistent with the
Constitution and others you might think
are inconsistent so what are the things
that presidents have claimed they've
claimed the authority to direct the
execution of federal statutes I think
that's consistent with the original
design they've claimed some limited
authority over foreign affairs I think
that too is consistent with the original
design
they've also claimed authority to
exercise certain powers and emergencies
that's more contested and more debatable
whether they have some sort of emergency
power either temporary or otherwise so
an Abraham Lincoln comes into power
Congress is not in session and Lincoln's
got to respond in real time to an
invasion on federal territory and to try
to begin to the protection of the United
States and he does that initially
without Congress being a part of it
because he has to move very quickly
they've also claimed the authority to
wage war and that's also contested
because of course Congress has the power
to declare war
and many people believe that that text
means that Congress gets to decide
whether to wage war modern presidents
take the position or often take the
position that they can use military
force overseas without getting a
declaration of war or more precisely
without getting congressional approval
for the use of force overseas so yes the
President's powers have changed over
time and that's the source of deep
controversy
so what checks can the executive branch
use on the legislative or judicial
branches of government Kim the executive
has a veto and the veto permits the
president to reject legislation sent to
his desk by Congress under the
Constitution Congress has to present all
legislation to the president and he can
either sign it and thereby make it law
or he can veto it and if he vetoes it
and he sends back his objections to
Congress they then have the option of
overriding the veto by a two-thirds vote
in both chambers and so the veto gives
you know the president great leverage
over Congress because they know that if
he vehemently opposes a particular piece
of legislation they can only pass it if
there are rather sizable super
majorities in both chambers he has a
power to be able to pardon people for
federal offenses so again that's a
unique presidential authority the
presidency in a sense has taken more of
the limelight away from Congress which
might be making the law but
administering the law is going to
require a lot more time and put the
president in the position of also
exercising discretion over how to
enforce the law so that becomes another
important authority of the presidency
how do you go about enforcing it what
kind of discretion do you have when you
do enforce it
he also has the power to recommend
measures to them under the Constitution
that is say you can suggest that they
pass legislation on a particular subject
thereby making sort of a vague
suggestion or he can actually present
them a bill and say I'd like you to
consider this they don't have to act on
the bill but he has that authority and
you know he can also tell them about the
State of the Union right that's the
state of the union clause
so though those are the checks he sort
of has on Congress and those are
significant checks right the you know
the members of Congress don't get paid
unless the president signs the bill that
passes the appropriation for them or
they override his veto so those are
significant checks and then with respect
to the judiciary Kim there isn't as many
there aren't as many checks in the
Constitution the Constitution never says
the executive branch has to execute
judgments issued by the courts but
that's been our practice and I think
it's an implicit feature of the
Constitution that when courts issued
judgments the executive will honor them
and enforce them because that's an
implicit feature of the Constitution
presidents don't really have much
leverage over the courts right because
the court the president does get to a
point it does get to nominate them and
does get to appoint them and that gives
him some sort of you know some sort of
say over who becomes a judge but once
they're judges he doesn't have any say
over what they decide and he typically
as I said enforces their judgments so
the check on the judiciary is who who
gets who gets into the federal courts
who who gets to serve as a federal judge
once their judges the president doesn't
have the same kind of check that he has
on Congress there's no veto on judicial
decisions for instance the president can
unilaterally or on his own issue what
are called executive orders which are
essentially mandates that govern the
operations within the executive branch
one president can set the priorities one
way but another president can reshape
them a different way interesting because
executive orders can do very positive
things like Truman's executive order
that the Armed Services be integrated
but they can also do very negative
things for example in turning Japanese
Americans during World War two that is
correct and so the executive orders
oftentimes might reflect a particular
president's values but again also
particular president's priorities the
challenge with an executive order is
that it only lasts longer than a
particular president's term if other
presidents are willing to sign off on
them as well
for example you can see see how
President Trump has decided not to
continue certain executive orders that
President Obama put into place just as
President Obama chose not to extend
certain executive orders president
george w bush put enterprise in into
place lots of rules and laws are not
made by congress in the modern era
they're made by executive and
independent agencies and so you know a
lot of the rules that we have to follow
about the environment or about labor or
about you know securities they come from
agencies and not directly from congress
and when the agency is an executive
agency the president not only appoints
the people that run that agency the
president's often the president or his
assistants in the White House are often
involved in crafting the rules and
shaping the rules in various ways and so
you know if we think the mass of rules
and legislation comes from the from the
government the executive and not the
Congress and the president has a great
role in that so our first president was
George Washington in what ways did
Washington set important precedents that
are still with us today
there are a lot of people a lot of
scholars and things who think that
things that have been quite different
headed not in Washington and the fact
that George Washington would would
become the first president helped put a
lot of people at ease because he was
widely viewed as trustworthy and
somebody who wouldn't be naturally
disposed to become tyrannical and
Washington himself understood from the
very outset of his administration that
nearly everything he did would create a
precedent for other presidents to follow
and so Washington ends up becoming quite
influential not just in helping define
things but also in reassuring people
that this system can get off the ground
and the presidency wouldn't necessarily
be a tyrannical office and that the
president in fact could be an effective
part of a new government
if Washington's not there and they can't
see an honest man taking over as
president you might very well have had
an executive counsel they might not they
might but it might have been wary of who
would be a unitary executive and wanted
to have
plural executive in order to make sure
that no one person became too powerful
and you know another way of thinking
about this is you know if you have a if
you create a new constitution in the
wake of President Nixon you're gonna
have a different Constitution because
people are more distrustful of executive
authority if you have a new constitution
after a really young you know honest and
Noble and you know successful presidency
people are gonna write an article to an
executive article that's more favorable
to the president and the situation for
Washington couldn't have been more
favorable they they had seen the
problems with weak execution under the
Articles and in the States they thought
that weak executives were a problem they
saw this person who could be a strong
executive and be responsible and why is
executive and those two things conspire
to create an executive that was one of
the most powerful in the world so
Washington is trying to signal look we
we don't want to create tyrants here
we're not kings we're not presidents for
life well serve at most for a couple
terms and then we will willingly lay
down our authority and let other people
follow us that's actually a critical
precedent but again every president
until wrote Franklin Roosevelt follows
and it's one that reflects Washington's
special values that the most important
office ultimately is not the office of
the presidency it's actually the office
so to speak the position of being a
citizen of this country so we've learned
that thanks to the example set by George
Washington the framers of the
Constitution felt confident that they
could invest power in a president to
have an energetic executive branch but
as sigh Prakash noted the framers might
be surprised at the way the president's
powers have grown over time through
executive orders and the use of military
force however Michael Gerhardt brings up
an important point that in the United
States the president is first and
foremost a citizen not a ruler to learn
more about article 2 visit the National
Constitution Center's interactive
Constitution and Khan Academy's
resources on US government and politics